most liquids when cooled will simply
shrink
water on the other hand actually expands
when it is frozen its volume will
increase by about nine percent
suppose you have one third of a gallon
of water
that gets frozen
what is the volume of the ice that you
now have so you're starting with
one-third of a gallon of water and they
tell us that when it when it gets frozen
when it turns into ice its volume is
going to expand by nine percent so the
new volume is going to be your existing
volume so this is the original volume
original
volume one third of a gallon and it's
going to expand by nine percent so your
frozen volume is going to be original
volume plus nine percent of your
original volume so plus
nine
percent
of your original volumes you could say
it's nine percent times one-third so
this right over here is going to be the
expanded volume now there's a bunch of
ways we can figure it out we could turn
things to decimals or whatever else but
they tell us to express
express your answer as a fraction so
let's make sure that everything here is
a fraction then we'll just try to
simplify so the one thing that's sitting
here that is not a fraction is our nine
percent well what does nine percent
actually represent well nine percent
literally means nine per hundred so we
can rewrite this as so this is going to
be equal to one third
plus instead of writing nine percent
i'll write that as nine per
hundred and then once again times
one-third
times
and we can simplify this expression
right over here we have a nine in the
numerator a three in the denominator if
we divide both of them by three we get a
three and a one and so we're left with
one third plus
three hundredths times one over one well
that's just going to be three hundredths
so this is just going to be equal to
one over three
plus i'll write this in orange still or
maybe i'll do it in a new color plus 3
over 100
plus 3 over 100 and now we have to add
something with half or two two numbers
that have different denominators so
let's find a common denominator so this
is going to be equal to
well the least common multiple of 3 and
is then they share no common factor so
it's really just going to be the product
of 300 the least common multiple is 300
so it's going to be something over 300
plus
plus something over
300 now to go from 3 to 300 in the
denominator you multiply by 100 so you
have to multiply the numerator by 100 as
well
so one-third is the same thing as 100
over 300 and to go from 100 to 300 we
had to multiply by 3 in the denominator
so we have to multiply by 3 in the
numerator as well so 3 hundredths is the
same thing as nine
nine three hundredths and now we're
ready to add this is going to be a
hundred plus nine over three hundred
which is one hundred and nine
over
three hundred so this is the volume of
ice that i now have expressed as a
fraction